الانفجار ضخم وقع السبت في مستودع للذخيره
في مدينه
خميليانسكي غربي اوكرانيا قيل انه حدث فجر
يوم السبت وشكل ما يشبه سحابه تذكرنا
بالانفجارات النوويه ونشاهد هذه الصور
مسيرات روسيه استهدفت بحسب الانباء مخازن
اسلحه تابعه للجيش الاوكراني ما تسبب في
انفجارين هائلين نجم عنهما اصابه اكثر من
20 شخصا متابع اللقطات قبل ان نستكمل
قوات الانفجار اعادت للاذهان ملف قذائف
اليورانيوم المنظم التي اعلنت بريطانيا
انها سترسلها الى اوكرانيا بافتراض ان
الانفجار ضم بعضا من قذائف اليورانيوم
المنضب فما الذي سيحدث في البدايه يستخدم
اليورانيوم المستنفذ في تصنيع الذخائر
بهدف اختراق الدروع مثل تلك الموجوده في
الدبابات والتي يصعب اختراقها احيانا
بالقذائف التقليديه انفجار هذه القذائف
يجعل اليورانيوم المنظم يشتعل ويتفكك الى
اجزاء تشكل رذاذا من الجسيمات الدقيقه
ويعتبر اليورانيوم المنظم اقل نشاطا
اشعاعيا من اليورانيوم الطبيعي لكن رغم
ضعف نشاطه الاشعاعي فان هذا الاشعاع يستمر
لالاف السنوات الخطر الرئيسي المرتبط
بذخائر اليورانيوم المستنفذ يتمثل في
استنشاق
انميات الماده المشعه بعد الانفجار ومثل
اي ماده مشعه هناك خطر الاصابه بالسرطان
من التعرض للاشعاع المنبعث من اليورانيوم
الطبيعي وايضا المستنفذ التعرض للجسيميات
عن طريق الاستنشاق سيضر بالكلى والكبد
والقلب كما انه سيزيد من خطر الاصابه
بسرطان الرئه والدماغ ايضا بالامكان ان
ننتقل او تنتقل هذه الجسيمات من خلال
انتقال اليورانيوم المنظم الموجود في
التربه الى المياه السطحيه والجوفيه التي
يتناولها البشر والحيوانات ايضا وكذلك
سيؤدي وجود اليورانيوم المنظم الموجود في
التربه وايضا في المياه الى ان تمتصه
النباتات ماء سينتقل و سينقله بطريقه اخرى
للبشر عند تناول الخضار والفاكهه لمتابعه
المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج والقصص
الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير الاخبا
ريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا على
اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس
التنبيهات